Cyber security is one of the fastest
growing and most respected fields today
and earning your CIS certification can
open the door to some of the highest
paying and most trusted roles in the
industry. But passing the CIS isn't just
about memorizing facts. It's about
understanding how to think like a
security leader. That's exactly what
this course is designed to do. I will
walk you through every domain, simplify
complex topics and share real world
example that will help you not only pass
the exam but truly master cyber
security. So before we begin, like this
video, hit that subscribe button and
turn on the notification bell.
So welcome to the domain number five,
identity and access management. And this
domain also carries a weightage of 13%
in overall CIS exam content. So let's
get started.
Identity and access management. So the
definition is that AM or ID AM both
these terms means identity and access
management. It is the foundation of
information security means it ensures
that only authorized
entities can access the resources. So
the key point here is to control access
to the your resources your assets so
that only authorized entities can access
these resources. So what are the
entities? Entities may be users system
applications or processes and the core
components of identity and access
managements are I aa that means
identification authentication
authorization and accountability.
So the first one is identification which
is establishing who the entity is. For
example, if the entity is user, the
identification may be the user username.
For example, the username may be John.
Next is the authentication which is
verifying the uh entity's identity. So
the authentication may be let's suppose
it may be password or in case of MFA it
may be password along with biometrics.
Next step is the authorization which is
granting access based on the permission.
So once John's logs into the application
or uh to the specific asset or resource
he may be given access to some specific
application some resources
that is based on uh his role. So that
means the authorization that what John
can do what action he can perform on
that specific application or resource
and the last step is the accountability
which is tracking and auditing actions.
So when John's performs certain actions
based on his authorization, these
actions are logs and tracks so that they
can be used for any purpose uh lately
and so that John cannot deny that he did
not perform such action. So the purpose
of accountability is to make someone
accountable if some unauthorized action
are performed even though the actions
were authorized. If they were performed
maliciously or for or for some uh
unauthorized purposes they can be make
accountable through accountability which
tracks and audits the user or entity
action.
So credential life cycle is the
provisioning maintenance and
deprovisioning. Credential as we spoke
may be the username and password. The
other credential maybe user may be given
hard uh token maybe also his biometrics
may also have been registered in the
form of MFA. So these are the three
steps in the credential life cycle.
First one is the provisioning which is
creating and assigning the credential.
It is the first step and it is usually
taken when a new employee joins the
organization. Next is the maintenance
which is reviewing and updating the
access regularly. These may be done when
let's suppose the employee or the user
he is promoted he is uh given some new
role. So they may be the access or the
credential may be updated. And the last
step is the deprovision which is
revoking access when they are no longer
needed. For example, when the employee
leaves the organization or when he is
terminated. So again, the goal of
identity and access management is to
ensure secure, auditable and appropriate
access across physical and logical
system.
So what do we mean by physical and
logical access to assets? So physical
access control means that we want to
physically control access to some
facilities and this may be through
doors, locks, fences, security guards
and barriers and the asset or the
facility may be for example your
or the organization data center or the
office building.
The purpose is to prevent unauthorized
entry to physical location for example
offices, server room, data, data centers
etc. So it is used to protect tangible
assets like equipment, hard copy of
document and other
physical assets. Logical access control
example include uh controls through
passwords, pins, biometric encryption
keys and access token. And the purpose
is to restrict access to digital systems
and data. Logical access control are
used to protect information assets and
ensure data confidentiality and
integrity.
So how to choose the access control? So
the selection of access control depends
on the asset value and security
priority. So for example, if you have
very high value physical assets, we need
stronger physical control rather we may
need multiple physical control. For
example, we may have fences,
uh security guards, barriers, locks and
door all these physical security
controls in place. And if we have uh
logical uh sensitive information system
then we need logical stronger technical
and logical control. For example,
instead of using only uh pins and
password, we may use MFA that is
multiffactor authentication which is
stronger than simple username and
password.
So what are some access control basics?
So we have these three components in
access control. First one is the subject
which may be the user process or device
that wants to access the resources or
that is requesting the access. Next is
the object which is the asset being
accessed. For example, a file, database,
facility. So these are assets. They are
known as objects. And the entities that
wants to access these objects are known
as subject. And access is of course
action a subject can perform on a
subject. For example, the uh subject can
read a file. It can write to the file
and the subject such as a person can
enter the physical facility which is the
object.
So security goals of uh the logical and
uh physical controls are you can say the
C.
So excess control protect these key
attributes which are summed in CIA and
and these include the our uh basic
pillar CIA which is confidentiality,
integrity, availability along with
non-repudiation and authenticity. So
non-rependuation is ensured by as we
studied in our previous side by
accountability.
Non-repudiation is that when a user or
system performs certain action that
system or user can later no longer deny
having performed that action and
authenticity is again we should be sure
that the user or the system or the
entity is the one who it claims it to
be.
So what is a system in identity and
access management? So a system includes
system may be hardware, software,
application, people, policies and
procedures. These all comes under the
umbrella of a system. So it typically
refers to electronic information system
but can also include analog or physical
component. So security practitioner must
understand how each component interact
to design effective identity and access
identity and access management control
for these systems.
So security objectives in system is what
are some objective that we want to have
in order to secure the system. So system
may require multiple security control
often again summarized through CIA
which is confidentiality
and confidentiality uh objective is to
keep information secure from
unauthorized access and example of
confidentiality may be a locked server
room which is a physical one or full
disk encryption which is a logical one.
So as we uh if you people recall
confidentiality can be ensured basically
through encryption. So here we can see
that logically full disk encryption for
example if you are using uh
you can say windows system. So the bit
locker gives us the facility of full
disk encryption. We can use bit locker
for full disk encryption. Next in
integrity which prevent unauthorized
modification of information. An example
of integrity
uh to ensure integrity uh we can use
hashing like the hashing algorithm SH
256 to detect any tampering with the
system files. Availability of the system
is that it ensure system and data remain
accessible. Example of availability may
be the log cabinet that prevent
accidental
shutdowns.
Non-repudiation ensure action cannot be
denied which requires strong logging and
identification. For example, digital
signature proves that a specific user
sent an email or approved a transaction
because the digital signature basically
carries the identity and authenticity of
a specific user. Authenticity is it
verifies that users data or commands are
genuine. For example, multiffactor
authentication confirm that the person
logging in is truly the authorized user.
So some important access control for
system. So identity and access
management ensure security and privacy
for data within system. Access control
support CIA principle by managing who
can access what and under what
conditions.
So identity and access management
administrator administration model. So
the uh how do these systems are uh
identity and access management system is
designed for protection of the system.
So the models may be centralized
administration which is managed by a
dedicated identity and access management
team or department. Advantages of this
type of system include that it is it has
the strong oversight and consistent
enforcement because it is centralized
and all the systems uh or you can say
object has the same identity and access
management policies and control.
Disadvantage is that it is single point
of failure and has and is less flexible.
So since it is centralized, if the
centralized system fails, it means the
AM solution of all the entities and
systems will fail.
Next model is the decentralized
administration which is managed by
individual system or data owner. So each
data owner or individual system manages
its own AM. Advantages include that it
provides greater flexibility and uh
faster decision. Disadvantage is that it
has the risk of inconsistent policies
and weaker oversight because each system
or each individual has its own system.
You cannot uh oversight uh efficiently
over all these system and of course each
one may have different policy which will
result in inconsistencies.
So what are devices uh in the identities
uh in identity and access management? So
we already studied that the system may
be devices and devices uh include
laptops, tablets and phone. So they are
complete information system and they
require access control to prevent
unauthorized use. Cloud and remote
access increase the number of devices to
secure.
So since uh the work from home scenario
the remote access and remote devices
number has increased as well as due to
the cloud. So we have uh more devices to
secure.
So devices may be as subject as well as
objects. So devices either act as a
object or as a subject. When they act as
objects, it mean devices contain
sensitive data that must uh restrict
access. For example, the laptop may have
some sensitive data on its hard drive
when they act as subjects. So then
devices authenticate themselves via
certificate, fingerprint or cookie. For
example, when you want to access a
server through the same laptop, it acts
then as a subject. So network access
control basically it can be used to
verify a devices health before granting
network access. For example, a personal
laptop is quarantine until page level
and end time detection and response
status are confirmed.
So how to protect the portable devices?
So the risk uh to the portable devices
include theft of these devices, loss on
unauthorized access when devices leave
secure areas. So they can be the
portable devices can be controlled via
MDM that is mobile device management and
these gives us the device protection. So
it enforces password complexity,
patching and application restriction via
the MDM which is a centralized uh you
can say mobile device management device
restriction. It can block jailbroken on
un or unsupported hardware to be used
inside the organization. Remote lock or
w. So it prevents access or erases data
if lost or stolen. So if the portable
device is lost or stolen, the uh device
can be remotely locked or the data can
be erased through MDM and
containerizations which isolates company
data on personal devices in BYOD
environments which is bring your own
device environment.
So what are some physical access
considerations? So in facility they are
protected by building access controls
which also we studied through locks
through fences through biometric.
Outside the facility user must follow
security best practices. For example
never leave devices unattended
and to never use and to use the safes
when staying at hotels and to conceal
devices while traveling.
So how to protect facilities through
identity and access management. So the
importance of uh facility is by facility
we mean the physical infrastructure such
as the office area, the server room, the
data center. So facilities protect
system, devices and data within them.
The physical security is essential.
It is essential because if attacker
gains physical access to the devices,
logical controls may fail. For example,
if you have a network device,
let's suppose a network switch and
firewall, it may have the password uh it
may be password protected. But if a user
gains physical access, he can uh break
the password through console and through
other means. So security should follow a
layer defense also known as defense in
depth approach.
So physical access control system also
known as packs. So packs basically
combine physical barriers,
identification methods and
administrative procedure to manage entry
and movement to facility. By movement we
mean physical movement and physical
entry inside facility. An example of
packs elements include user
identification which can be done through
badges, RFID tags or QR codes which
identify people and vehicles. Device
identification which is through RFID
tags are stickers which track assets
that enters or leaves the facility.
Fences and gates basically define the
boundaries and guide access through
control points. Secure door means uh
secure door may require the
authentication through smart card,
mobile application or pin. Lock and keys
control
access to rooms or equipment. For
example, the lock and keys may be
mechanical or digital such as the
digital which may the door may open
through digital pins. Intrusion sensors
basically detect unauthorized entry and
the sensor may be heat sensor, sound or
pressure sensor. Trans or Mantra
basically limit access to one person at
a time and prevent piggy banking. Piggy
banking means when a person authorized
person is entering a facility and an
unauthorized just follows that person to
enter the facility. CCTV surveillance is
uh to monitor and record activity of all
the movement. So modern AI cameras can
detect motion or specific objects. Plots
are basically dynamic. They provide
dynamic human oversight which is highly
effective but also costly.
The emergency consideration must be keep
in mind uh kept in mind while designing
the facilities identity and access
management. So packs must follow quick
safe eress during emergency for example
fire or active threat. So secure door
should fail open or trigger alarm to
protect human life while maintaining
accountability.
So what are the key takeaways? So
effective facility identity and access
management combine physical barriers
identification system and human
oversight to protect critical assets
ensuring security, safety and
operational continuity. So you need
physical barriers such as the you can
say the gates, the trans, the bolards,
identification systems such as maybe
biometric system, beige uh badge based
system and human overides such as the
CCTV are the guard which oversees the
overall facility
uh entrance at exit points.
So where comes the application in
identity and access management? how to
uh control access to applications. So
the principle of access control is that
access to application must follows need
to know and least privilege principles
which are the you can say basic
principle for all uh access to the
resources and assets. Applications are
gateway to organizational data.
Therefore improper access can expose
sensitive information.
So applications uh as subjects and
objects. Application sometimes acts as
object and sometime as objects. When
they act as object, application can act
autonomously. For example, automated
jobs, schedule task and require
permissions.
When they act as object, application
themselves may require controlled access
or licenses and they are then accessed
by other subjects. So managing
application access and licenses is
essential especially in large
organizations.
So the access consideration to
applications include access to
application where the user should only
access applications relevant to their
job. As we already studied the need to
know basis access should be the need to
know basis. For example, HR staff do not
need access to accounting application
and vice versa. Accounting staff does
not need access to uh HR application. So
use role based access control that is
arbback to assign permissions
efficiently. What does this mean? This
means that let's suppose for HR staff
you have made a role let's suppose an HR
role and this has all the required
permission
uh to the HR application and any user
that is in HR is then assigned this
role. So it is easy to manage and
implement.
Next is access by application to data.
So application themselves do not uh have
the data. Application in fact access
data from the databases and other
systems such as storage or DB. So
application themselves may need data
access. This must be controlled. For
example, in MDM or mobile device
management containerized application
prevent personal application from
accessing corporate data.
Another access consideration is the
access within application. So
application often have different user
role. For example, user simple user
versus the admin or administrator.
Granularity defines how precisely access
can be managed. High granularity means
that access to specific folder or
records is controlled and row low
granularity means that to simply allow
or deny for the whole application. So
poor granularity can lead to accidental
data exposure.
So key takeaways are that effect
effective identity access and access
management for applications balances
user access app to data controls and
internal access granularity
ensuring data remains secure while
maintaining operational efficiency.
So how to manage identification and
authentication of people devices and
services.
So as we studied that the core identity
and access management functions include
identification, authentication,
authorization and accountability.
So every
system must include identification which
establishes who the subject is, who the
user is or who the system is that wants
to access to the data or the uh
resources. Authentication is proving the
identity is genuine through
authentication types such as MFA,
biometric, user, password. Authorization
is granting access rights to the
resources based on their role based on
their uh the user type or the system
type. Accountability is the last step
where we track and log the user or
system actions.
So our first step in uh identity access
uh management core function is the
identification. So a subject which may
be a user device or process asserts an
identity for example a username and or
an ID card. So these are types of the
identities. This step happens before
authentication or access attempts. So
the first step is identification.
The the system or the user presents the
identity such a username. The system
then asks for the authentication maybe
through a password through biometric. So
this form the basis of user management
and provisioning.
The next step is the authentications
which proves the claimed identity using
one or more factors. So we have diff
different factors of authentication.
Type one is something you know which is
based on password or pin. So this is
something the user or the system know or
remembers. Type two is something you
have. For example, uh the user may have
the smart card, the smartphone or some
other hard hardware token. So based on
these devices, the ownership of these
devices, they can authenticate
themselves. Type three is something you
are. So this is part of the
physiological or physical uh behavior or
structure of the user. For example,
biometric traits like fingerprints or
facial data. These are something the
user or are the actually physically
belongs to the user. A type four is
context based which is based on the user
or system location device behavior and
which then triggers adaptive MFA. What
does this mean? This mean that let's
suppose a user usually logs in from a
country X. So it uh uses the normal uh
let's suppose factor let's suppose it
uses the password or pin but when let's
suppose on suddenly the user logs in
from another location why where he or
she never logged in before from that
location. So such scenario may trigger
the MFA. So since now this behavior is
suspicious the user may be required to
authenticate using multiffactor
authentication.
Authorization is uh the process which
assigns and verifies permissions for a
subject. It happens during provisioning
and each uh access request. So during
provisioning first the user or the
system is authorized such and arrives
and when each time the user wants to
access a resource this request request
is then matched against the
authorization. So this ensures user only
access what they are approved for on the
principle of least privilege.
And number five is the accountability
which re uh records and monitor user or
system actions and this uh enables then
auditing compliance checks and
investigation.
So key takeaways is that effective IM
ensures the right person or device gets
the right access verified controlled and
monitored through these core function
which is identity authentication
authorization and accounting.
So identity management implementation.
So the purpose of identity management
implementation is that it manages user
identities across multiple systems for
example emails application and external
tools.
So these systems the identity management
they supports authentication
authorization and accountability through
proven identities. It can the system can
be a standalone tool or part of a
broader identity and access management
system. So the key function of identity
management include provisioning. So this
is the first step where we create users
identity for example the username and
assign initial access often through HR
or manager.
Then we uh finally uh do the
deprovisioning which is the process of
suspending or deleting accounts when
users leave or change roles. Account
management is the centralized or
selfservice password reset and updates.
It also has the function of
authorization management which assign
permissions by placing users into rows
and groups. And identity review is the
regularly audit uh it regularly audit
user re user access for appropriateness
and revoke access privileges.
For example, sometime when the user
changes role
uh let's suppose the user goes from one
role to another role the access
permissions or the access right of the
previous role are also with the user. So
the uh review basically checks these
accesses so that these roles are then
terminated and the user now have the
roles or the access rights of the new
role.
So additional features of identity
management include the SSO or single
sign sign on which is the uh one login
grants access to multiple system using
authentication tokens. So SSO as the
name indicates single sign on. So if the
organization has let's suppose multiple
applications.
So instead of user having to uh use
separate username and password for each
application let's suppose we have
three application.
So the SSO basically enables a single
credential which then enable the user to
access all the application. That's why
it is named as the single sign on. So
pros is that we have fewer password. So
we have single password and username for
all these three application which gives
us improved security and user
convenience. Improved security in the
sense that let's suppose if this uh
password is uh compromised we can
centrally
delete the password or reset it. And
convenience is that we don't have to
manage three separate username and
passwords for all the application. Only
uh one password and one credential from
a centralized system such as ad ADR
active directly will give a revoke
access to all the application. Cons
include single point of failure. So if
the SSO is down or compromised all link
system are affected. So it is a downside
that if the SSO system does not work the
user will be logged out or won't be able
to access all the application.
But on the other side recovery is
easier. Disabling one account blocks
access to all system. So it is uh the on
the flip side recovery of the password
is also uh easier because uh resetting
one password give access to all the
application. So disabling one account
block access to all system. Similarly if
the account is compromised disabling
this account revoke access to all
system. So federation basically enables
trust and identity sharing between
organizations.
The key takeaways is that identity
management streamlines identity life
cycle management from account creation
to deactivation while SSO enhances
convenience but must be balanced against
centralized risk.
So what are some authentication factors
that we talked about in our previous
slide? So we may have uh two type of
authentication either it is single
factor-based or multiffactor
authentication known as MFA. So we have
these types of factor. Type one is
something you know as we already
discussed password pin or a question.
Type two is something you have such as
smart card phone or authenticator
application. and type three is something
you are such as fingerprint, iris or
facial recognition.
So single factor authentication is
basically based on any one of these
types. So it uses only one factor for
example usually the password. It is
common but less secure. So password is
vulnerable to theft, fishing as well as
guessing. Example of single factor
authentication is username plus
password. So this is type one only. So
this type of uh authentication is single
factor because it uses only one type of
authentication factor. On the other
hand, multiffactor authentication uses
two or more different factor types for
verification. So this is important.
uh if you use password
plus spin it is still single factor
authentication because they belongs to
the same type one factor. So the factor
types must be different uh in order for
it to be a true multiffactor
authentication. So this strengthens
security by requiring multiple proofs of
identity. Example include password which
is type one plus authenticator app code
which is type two. Password is something
you know and this authenticator app is
something you have. So this is two
factor and if you use uh three types
such as pass one type one code type two
and finger type three then it uh is
known as multiffactor authentication.
Sometime the two factor authentication
is also interchangeably known as
multiffactor authentication.
Anything uh greater than one is
multiffactor
uh authentication.
So key notes are that multiple same time
factors for example password plus
security question is not equal to uh
MFA. It is uh uh still single factor
authentication. MFA must be from two
factors, different factor types.
Balancing security versus usability is
essential. MFA reduces risk for fishing
and credential theft. Though advanced
realtime fishing attacks can still
bypass it. So it means that there are
still threats to MFA such as advanced
real time.
So now coming over to uh the different
type of factors uh in detail. So type
one authentication factor is something
you know for example password PIN or a
security question which is this type of
factor type one authentication factor is
very common and widely supported across
system. So it is updated in NIST uh SP80
800-63B
guidance which says to focus on
usability or complexity
for example uh easy to remember past
phrase. So this is recommended easy to
remember past phrase. For example,
uh maybe an example I go to office
at 9. So this is uh a type of phrase
that is easy to remember
but also
very uh strong.
So the
then we have uh the length is greater
than complexity. So this is you can say
it is long and if you use something like
let's suppose 1 9 6
dollar sign
uh a b c something like that. So this
one is strong than this complex
password. For example, riskbased
security is the future. This is a phrase
that you can remember. It is uh good to
have such long phrase than a complex
password like this. So you should change
it only if compromised not routinely
because you remember it. Weakness is
that it can be forgotten or stolen.
Nowhere to verify who is using it. We
are talking about single factor
authentication. So if someone uh gains
access to your password or pin, you
never know who is using it. On the other
hand, you are biometric uh no one else
can fill it through these regular means.
So we have then the password manager. So
these securely store and autofill
passwords in an encrypted vault. So they
generate strong random passwords
automatically. user remembers only one
master password that unlocks the
password manager. So password manager
basically support backup recovery and
admin access with auditing. So
compromise of master password or admin
abuse can expose credential.
Now coming over to type two
authentication factors which is
something you have. Example include
smart cards, ID badges, digital
certificates, trusted devices and
authenticator apps as well as tokens. So
you do not need to remember anything
unlike passwords
and this must uh you must physically
possess the device to authenticate. So
if you have the trusted device or your
ID badge or smart card then you can
authenticate to the system. Otherwise if
the device or the badge or smart card is
not physically with you, you cannot
authenticate to the system. So security
consideration of type two authentication
factors are that they may be lost,
stolen or unpowered devices and then
they it can prevent login. So user must
keep devices physically secure
and uh report the user must report the
lost or stolen devices immediately so
that some unauthorized user don't use
them. The organization must train help
desk staff for the incident response and
use central consoles to revoke or
dregister lost tokens.
What are some weak practices? weak
practices uh that should be avoided
include avoiding SMS or email for
one-time passwords. So uh receiving OTP
where SMS is no longer secure. It should
be avoided. So these channels are not
secure and can be intercepted. So prefer
authenticator apps or hardware tokens.
Now coming over to type three
authentication factors which is
something you are or something you do.
So these include biometric measurements
like fingerprints, facial recognition,
retina scans, bias pattern and typing
rhythm. So this is also uniquely
identifies a typing rhythm uniquely
identifies a user and it is often used
as a second or third third factor in
multiffactor authentication. For
example, the first factor may be
password and the second factor may be
fingerprint biometrics. So this these
features are this factor is highly
unique highly unique. It is hard to fake
or uh duplicate and provides strong
identity uh assurance as compared to the
password to the hardware token. Password
can be stolen, hardware uh token or
smart card can be lost or stolen but
your fingerprint always stays with you.
So this gives strong identity uh
assurance.
What are some strength and weaknesses of
type three authentication factor?
Strength include that it is diffic diff
difficult to duplicate or share. It
provides strong proof of identity and
weaknesses include that there are some
cultural issues with these factor. For
example, facial or hand scan may be
unacceptable in some region. For
example, uh in some region where uh the
women some religion or region do not
want to uncover their faces. So there
may be some issues with uh cultural
issue with the system. Accessibility is
that is not suitable for all user. For
example, for user with disabilities
or it may also have some hygiene concern
because when each one is uh using for
example especially if you people
remember during COVID 19
it was specifically uh this concern that
let's suppose if you have a biometric uh
system at the entrance there was a very
great chance of COVID spread because uh
due to the contact with this system.
Similarly, body change. So, illness or
aging can affect recognition. For
example, with aging, the fingerprint
pattern they uh change or sometime they
uh vanish all together from uh at older
ages. It cannot be changed easily. So,
if compromised biometric data is
permanent, you cannot change your
fingerprint uh data. It is permanent as
it is from birth till death. So it is
also the privacy risk. So biometric data
is belongs to the PII class of data
which is personally identifiable uh
information and it must be protected.
Security consideration again included is
we must ensure liveless detection to
avoid spoofing with the photos or
recording. For example, if someone has
your uh photo,
it can use it for the facial uh scanning
or facial recognition. So therefore, the
system must have the liveless detection
so that it only grants access if it is
actually live person.
The system should also allow updating
biometrics when physical traits change.
For example, if your typing speed
change, if your voice somehow change,
the system should be able to update
these changes and uh store and process
biometric data securely with privacy
safeguard. So biometric data as we
studied it is sensitive PII data. So it
must be stored and processed securely
through safeguards.
Now coming over to common access control
errors. So these the false rejection.
First one is false rejection which
belongs which is a type one error. This
is a type of error where system denies
access to an authorized person. So this
is false rejection. The user was fastly
rejected although he was or she was
authorized. Example include fingerprint
reader fails to recognize a valid user.
Number two access control error is Paul
acceptance which is opposite of this one
which is type two error where a system
grants access to an unauthorized user.
Example face scanner incorrectly accepts
another person. So this one is more
serious than this one due to obvious
reason.
So error measurement and balance. So we
have the false rejection rate also known
as F FRR which measures how often valid
users are rejected. Then we have the
false acceptance rate or F A R which
measures how often unauthorized users
are accepted.
And then there is a measurement known as
CER
which is crossover error rate which is
the point where FR is equal to F A R. So
lower C or lower crossover error rate
means better accuracy.
So the cost versus risk consideration is
that high cost system may have low F
that is low fast acceptance rate but
higher F FRR which means they are more
secure but less convenient because they
are uh their rejection uh false
rejection rate is high but false
acceptance rate is low. So low cost
system may have higher uh F that is
fault acceptance rate which is less
secure and more convenient
but this one is not intended we can go
with this one but this one is you can
say uh more risky. So choose based on
asset value and acceptable risk. So if
the risk is low, the asset is of uh low
value, then you can choose this one. And
if the risk is high and asset is of high
value, then we should choose this one,
the high cost system.
Accountability. Accountability as we
already studied basically ensures users
and processes are responsible for their
action. It is based on identification.
So we can make accountable uh we can
make someone accountable if you first if
you are able to first identify them. So
it is identification is knowing who
performed the action. Next is uh
authentication which is verifying the
identity. So the user
uh verified its identity through
authentication factor that we studied
and then logging and monitoring which is
tracking and reviewing user activity
that whatever first user logged in and
then it performs certain action that we
track through logging and monitoring. So
strong authentication that is MFA
required to enfor is required to enforce
accountability
and shared credential make it impossible
to take action. So if you have if the
user have username and password
it can be easily shared and then the
accountability is very strong to
establish. On the other hand, the MFA
let's suppose if the system requires
username and password as well as the
fingerprint, it is very difficult to
share with other users. So therefore, we
can say that MFA
uh ensure or enforce strong
accountability. So define the required
level of accountability during system
design. So these system these things the
level of accountability are incorporated
during system designs.
Example of accountability include
financial management system which
require strong accountability for
example MFA and audit because these
systems are of high value because these
deal with finances. Then is the internal
social platform which may require basic
username and password which will be
sufficient for these type of systems.
Enforcing accountability. So
accountability can be enforced through
auditing that is reviewing
and verifying the logged activities and
separation of duties or sod which is
splitting responsibilities to prevent
misuse. For example, one user submits
expenses and another approves it. So a
single user does not submit as well as
approve the expenses which this process
is known as separation of duties.
Session management. So a session is an
exchange between devices. For example,
an exchange between a client and a
server. It is used to maintain user
state like items in an online shopping
cart. So the HTTP protocol is stateless.
So sessions make web interactions
stateful. Each session is tracked using
a unique session ID.
So how does the session work? So the
user logs in, session is created and
then server issues session ID. So
session ID is stored in a cookie and
sent with each request.
This allows the server to remember user
action for example checkout cart.
So there are some common session attacks
which include the session hijacking
where attacker impersonates a user for
example through the man in the middle
attack. Another is session replay where
which reuses the intercepted session
tokens.
Then we have the session side jacking
which steals session cookies through
packet packet sniffing. And last one is
the session fixation which is the which
reuses or sets non session ID to hijack
authentication.
So some session security best practices
from Oest and these include to use
strong and random session ids which can
be long and unpredictable to never
include user data such as username and
password in session token. to use HTTPS
and mark cookies as secure and HTTP only
and to regenerate session ids after
login or privilege changes and to
terminate session after inactivity or
log out.
Our next topic is the registration,
proofing and establishment of identity.
So user access begins with the creation
of an identity. So this requires user
information and verification by the
organization and this can range from a
simple such as choosing a username for
an online application or a complex such
as submitting government verified ID for
sensitive access.
So these are some NIST uh SP800-63-3
digital identity guidelines and these
define identity assurance level that is
I based on risk and required proofing
strength.
So the identity assurance levels include
identity assurance level one which is
user where user self asserts identity.
No verification is required from the
provider side and it is used where low
accountability is needed. For example
basic web application. So this is this
you can say that this is used for basic
identity assertion. This is the lowest
level. Next is the identity assurance
level two where identity documentations
are required maybe remotely or in person
and this links user to real world
identity. It is common for employment
verification.
And next one is the identity assurance
level three IL3 which is the highest
assurance level. And this one requires
inperson proofing with the
governmentisssued ID and verified by
trained cloud service provider staff for
maximum confidence.
So establishing identity is once
proofing is complete an identity is
created and stored. For example, uh uh
example of identity uh creation include
creating the user account, giving the
user the facility base or authentication
token. So visitor access may use
simplified proofing for example ID check
plus giving the visitor the visitor
badge.
What are some security considerations?
These include system must protect
authenticity, confidentiality and
integrity. So authenticity as we already
studied verifies that users are genuine,
confidentiality protects user data and
integrity prevents tampering with
identity records.
So the impacts of failure uh of these
factors can include reputation loss,
data leaks and safety risk.
An example include airport employees. So
the greeter may be given uh may be
required I A2 or identity assurance
level two which is basic ID spoofing
while the mechanic working working uh
inside the can and say aeroplanes may
require identity assurance level three
which is in depth verification for
safety safety critical roles.
So what is federated identity management
or FIM? So federated identity management
basically allows a user to authenticate
once and access multiple federated
system just like the SSO. So the
participating systems trust each other's
authentication
and it is common among business partners
collaborating on projects and divisions
within the large organizations which
have separate IT systems. So this type
of organization or system use federated
identity management. What are some
benefit of federated identity
management? This includes simplify
fim simplifies access for user such as
SSO also simplifies the access. It
reduces administrative overhead of
managing multiple accounts and easier uh
it has the easier account creation and
deprovisioning across systems again like
SSO because we have uh few uh ids that
are used across multiple system and it
improves user experience and streamlines
operations.
What are some risk and consideration
with federated identity management? So
shared trust means shared risk. What
does this mean? This means that if uh
employee of organization A uh do
something malicious or is a malicious
actor, the trust of the other
organization which to which the identity
is federated will also be lost.
So security depends on the weakest
federation federated organization.
So if one entity has poor identity
management, it can compromise all
federated system. So risk assessment and
mutual security standards are essential.
Key takeaway. So federation provides
convenience and efficiency but must be
built on mutual trust and strong
security controls between all
participating organizations.
Our next topic is CMS that is credential
management systems. So a credential
basically links an authenticator such as
password and certificate to an
identifier for example the username
username. So credential management
system manages the entire life cycle of
these credential and the life cycle is
basically based on provisioning,
auditing and deprovisioning.
Example of credential management systems
include password manager, registration
authorities and certification
authorities or CA in PKI.
So the key component in the PKI as we
know are the RA that is registration
authority which is responsible for
performing the identity proofing and
also verification of user information be
before issuing the certificate.
TA that is certificate authority on the
other hand issues and validates the
digital certificates and ensure that the
certificates are authentic and trusted
and are issued by the uh trusted CAS.
So some core credential management
system functions. First one is the
enrollment which includes the collection
of user identity details. Then is
identity proofing which is the
validation of the claim identity. Then
the credential issuance which creates
and provides the credential life cycle
management which maintains and audits
credentials and deprovisioning which
finally revokes and suspends unused and
expired credential.
So what are the enrollment process
steps? So this was the core function of
CMS and the steps include the
sponsorship. So the employee or
authority that authorizes the credential
request
uh it will be HR most of the time inside
an organization. Then the enrollment in
the enrollment the user submits identity
information based on a required identity
insurance level.
Then the credential production. So the
system generates credentials for example
beige certificate and smart card
and issuance where the credentials are
finally issued to the user. Life cycle
management so includes audits, renewals,
suspension and revocation of these
credentials.
Single sign on or SSO we already studied
about uh SSO. So let's deep dive about
SSO. What is SSO? What are its pros and
cons? So SSO provides an unified login
experience where user authenticates once
to access multiple system. It simplifies
access by using one set of credentials
for several applications.
So common SSO approaches include web
based dashboard or portal. So in this
type of approach, the user logs into a
central website.
It then accesses other applications via
the stored credential that were logged
in for the first time. It is useful for
legacy or nonfederated application.
Then we have the federated identity SSO.
In this case, the user logs in once, for
example, Microsoft 365 or Google
Workforce and then can access external
applications using the same
organization's
credential. For example, when you log in
using your Gmail account, using the same
account, you can then access your inbox.
the uh Google Drive,
YouTube.
So these all are different application
but since these all are trusted
application of one organization that is
Google or you can say more correctly
alphabet. So using one set of credential
you can then access multiple
applications which you can say it is f
federated identity SSO.
What are some benefits of SSO? So in SSO
few you require fewer passwords to
remember
but you also need a stronger password
chassis since you have only one password
to use in SSO that password must be
strong or else you can use MFA as well
which is recommended for such system. So
it reduce reduces user frustration and
simplifies account management. It has
the centralized logging which is easy
for monitoring and auditing and faster
response. It enables faster response
which means disabling one account
disabled disables all the linked
application to that specific SSO
account.
So what are some risk and drawbacks of
SSO for first one? First one and
foremost is the uh single point of
failure. So if the SSO account is
compromised or uh is user is unable to
use it to login using this account it
means all the connected application with
that account are either exposed or are
unavailable to the user. It requires
strong authentication for example M MFA
to mitigate risk. So to mitigate this
risk
of stolen or compromised credential you
need MFA. So federation or integration
errors can affect multiple system. What
does this mean? This means that if there
is some issue with the SSO system and
the user is unable to log in using his
SSO credential, it means all the system
linked to that account areed.
It means again the user cannot access
any of these application since the SSO
system is down or uh affected due to any
integration or federation.
What is just in time or JIT identity and
access management. So the purpose of J
is that it grants access only when
needed and only for the required
duration
and it reduces the risk of risk from
compromised or ideal accounts. How does
uh it do this? So if your account or the
some account is compromised
it the just in time uh removes or
reduces this risk because after certain
period of time the account will be
automatically disabled due to this
feature of just in time it may be let's
suppose enabled for 8 hours for 24
hours. So even if your account is
compromised it will be automatically the
access will be removed. Similarly, idle
account are also automatically
uh revoked or their access is revoked
due to just in time feature.
So what are some cases uh that uh are
use cases for just in time? Use case one
is ondemand identity creation. So
identities are created only when access
is requested. For example, when
employees uh joins the organization,
basic account of the new employee is
created. Additional system access
provision automatically upon first use.
So when the account is first used,
additional access is then given.
TL uh used to automatically create and
authorize identity. We will uh study
about the
ML uh in a while. So it reduces the
admin overhead and supports role based
access.
Use case two is the privileged account
management or PAM. So this controls
highlevel admin accounts. Credential are
stored in a secure wallet and access is
granted temporarily when evaluate when
elevated privileges are required and it
logs and monitors each privilege
escalation event.
So security controls in just in time and
uh just in time privileged account
management. So break glass process this
is another important concept which is
access requires deliberate action for
example manual approval. What does this
this means that when
privilege
account management or privilege account
uh access is required you have to do
something such as you have to you can
say that this account is behind the
glass. you have to break the glass and
uh practical example is
sorting or uh getting manual approval
from the management. So this ensure that
only intentional privilege uh privileged
account is used. It is not accidental or
for other uh malified purposes. time
limited credential so access expires
automatically after a set period and
passwords are token rotate post expiry.
So key benefit of just in time uh and
ident identity and access management is
that it minimizes insider threat and
exposure time. As we studied that if
account is compromised, it will be
exposed for a very short period of time
after which account will will be
automatically
uh access will be reco revoked or
account uh privileges will be revoked.
It enforces least privilege principle
and improves auditing and access
visibility.
So use case two is the privilege account
management. So I think we already
studied about this. This is the same
slide and uh this is how the just in
time identity and access management
works. So we have a normal user but due
to specific requirement this user now
needs uh elevated access. So he will
request git or just in time request. So
his privileges will be elevated
temporarily and after a certain period
of time let's suppose 1 hour or 2 hour
or 8 hour as per the uh system
configuration the privilege will be auto
revoked
identity with a third party service also
known as identity as a service or ID A.
So identity as a service extends
federated identity by providing
third-party identity management across
internal and external system. It
implements federation standard like SL
and Oath by default and it enables
integration with both legacy and cloud
system.
Benefits of identity as a service are
that it simplifies collaboration across
organization. It reduces administrative
overhead and it provides native support
for cloud application.
So some risk uh with this process or
identity as a service are that it is a
single point of failure if the identity
as a service system or the service goes
down. Loss of control over identity data
for example data breach at provider. So
since your identity provision is now
dealt by a third party. So if there is
some issue with that third party it
means your data will be also at risk or
it may be compromised.
So on premises identity and access
management. So this is the identity
access management which is hosted within
the organization for example through
LDAP or Microsoft active directory. It
offers total control over your hardware
software and configuration means it is
wholly solely controlled and configured
by the organization itself. So it
support strong security customization
but it also require higher maintenance
cost because you need
technical team you need hardware
software to manage all these. It has
limited federation capability with
external and cloud system since it is
designed for internal onremises system
only and it has the risk of
misisconfiguration due to complexity of
the system.
Then we have the cloud-based identity
and access management which is suited
for cloud first or cloud migrating
organization. Identity as a service acts
as an identity and access manager broker
which means managing access for cloud
and federated services. It supports just
in time or git provisioning for
automatic account creation upon first
login.
It integrates easily with software as a
service platform reducing the
administrative tasks.
What is hybrid identity as a uh hybrid
identity and access management and
federated identity with a third party
service. So this combines both on
premises IM and cloud-based identity as
a service. For example, on premises
active directory plus cloud Azure AD
synchronization.
This offers unified credential and SSO
like experience. Advantages is that
smooth migration path from legacy to
cloud system and it unifi gives unified
user experience.
Some risk include the dual maintenance
overhead for both the on premises and
the cloud identity as a service system.
It is shared with third party. It shares
third party risk from the cloud side and
it has the potential for expanded attack
surface if identity as a service is
compromised.
So how to implement and manage
authorization
mechanisms? So what is authorization? We
already studied about authorization.
Authorization determines what action a
subject which may be a user, a process
or a system is allowed to perform on an
object such as file, system, data,
server etc.
So it occurs the authorization occurs
before access. So during user enrollment
authorization is defined. For example,
when the user is created along with the
creation, there is authorization or the
user access permission are also created.
So during the time of access when user
tries to open or use a resource again
the authorization is checked.
So why does the authorization matter? So
in small system access control can be
managed manually but in large
organization with hundred of users and
millions of resources manual management
becomes impossible. Therefore a
structured access control model is
essential to handle complex
authorization efficiently and securely.
So the purpose of access control model
are to uh define relationship between
subjects and objects and to enforce who
can access what supporting key security
principle including the conf
confidentiality which means that only
authorized users can view data integrity
meaning only authorized users can modify
data and authenticity which ensures the
identity of user. users performing
action.
So now coming over to some common access
control models and these include DAC
that is discretionary access control
where resource owners decides to decides
about the access they can give access to
whom however they want. Next is the MAC
which is mandatory access control which
is access based on system enforced
classification level.
Next is the Rback which is role based
access control where access is based on
a user's job or role. Next is the rule
based access control where access is
granted based on specific condition or
rules. And last one is the
attribute-based access control or ABG
where access is determined by attributes
such as user, resource and environment
access control models overview and our
first model is role based access control
that is our back.
So in this model access is granted based
on roles that are assigned to user. For
example, the role may be an HR role,
admin role or security analyst role. For
example, a security analyst may read and
write to a seam solution. SIM is
security information and event
management solution
while assistment ad system admin may
have no access to the same SIM solution
based on role.
Similarly, the role or arback role based
solution basically prevents toxic role
combination. For example, same user
cannot be both admin as well as the
analyst because these two are toxic role
combination and benefit of our back is
that it enforces least privilege and
accountability
and it simplifies management. So we need
to assign role instead of per user
permission. So how does we it simplifies
management. So for example, if an
organization has let support 50
employees that need uh usernames uh and
credentials. So instead of managing the
permission for all these users
individually which will be very
cumbersome.
What we can do? We can uh make roles.
For example, if there are 25 employees
in HR department, we can define an HR
role. give permission to this HR role as
per the requirement and then add all the
25 user to that role. Similarly, if the
rest of the 25 user belong to the
finance department, we can add these two
finance uh role or the finance group and
the finance group permissions are then
managed. So in this way it greatly
simplifies the management. Next is the
rulebased access control that is you can
say rubback and in this model the access
is granted by predefined rules or
conditions. Example include firewall
rules such as allowing or denying IP
addresses or ports and file access
control list such as defining readr
permissions for file.
So key terms that uh can be used or that
uh are uh used in this uh model include
the implicit hello where everything is
loud unless explicitly denied. For
example, if I give an example of this I
can give example through a device which
is a network switch. So this switch by
default allows everything when you
connect system with it they will be able
to communicate with each other without
any denials. So this is an example of
implicit allow. The next is the implicit
deny where everything is denied unless
explicitly allowed which is the best
practice from the security perspective.
An example of this can be again a
network firewall which denies everything
by default and you have to allow certain
services
or uh IP addresses that you want to
allow.
Next is the mandatory access control or
MAC where access is granted based on
security labels and the labels may be
top secret and confidential.
This model is b mainly used in military
or government systems and an example of
this model is when a secret user cannot
access top secret files
and models. So these two model that we
already studied in domain one
laulla and biba they are based on
mandatory access control. So as we
studied bar labadulla basically focuses
on confidentiality while biba model
focuses on integrity.
So this model is nondiscretionary
because it is not up to the individual
user discretion to assign rights. The
rights are enforced by system through
security
labels.
So let's go to the next
access control model which is
discretionary access control model or
deck
where owners decide who can access their
objects. It is up to the discretion of
the owner. An example is that a document
document owner gives read access to all
the user while added access to very
specific users. Benefit of this model is
that it is flexible and decentralized
because each user maintain its own
permissions. Drawback is that uh
inconsistent permissions across
organization and potential insider
misuse and it is commonly used in file
system and social media content sharing.
Number fifth is the attribute-based
access control or a back where access
decision are based on attributes
attributes of user objects and
environments. An example is that access
is allowed during business hours from an
authorized device access to a system an
application or a server etc. So these
business stars and an authorized device
you can say that these are basically
attributes that allows access benefits
is that it is dynamic and context aware.
So it supports adaptive authentication
and it is used in stateful firewalls and
cloud environments.
Number six is the risk based access
control where which adjust access
dynamically based on current risk level
and thread data. For example, increase
multiffactor authentication requirements
during fishing attacks. So if there are
increased fishing attacks, the MFA
requirements are increased. And to block
suspicious login based on seam alerts.
So if there are threats there will be
alerts and so the suspicious login are
then blocked. So that's why we say that
access is dynamic.
So it is used by banks and financial
system for fraud detection. Advantage is
that it is real time and adaptive
security that evolves with threat
intelligence.
So this is the summary of all these
access control models. First one is the
role bake access control which was based
on role for example HR and admin roles
and key advantage of this one is that it
simplifies management.
Then we have the rulebased access
control which is based on rules. An
example is the firewall access control
list and this one gives very granular
control. Next is the mandatory access
control which is based on classification
labels for example top secret system
secret system etc and it gives very high
confidentiality and is used in
government agencies and military
environment. Next is the discretionary
access control where access decision is
on owner discretion
and an example of this one is file
sharing and it is flexible but also
risky.
Next one is the attribute-based access
control which is based on attributes and
policies. An example of this one is time
device and location. And key advantage
of this one is that it is uh it provides
contextbased access. And last one is the
risk based access control where which is
based on dynamic threat level. And an
example of this one is adaptive
multiffactor authentication
and it gives a realtime defense.
Our next topic is identity and access
provisioning life cycle.
So the first step in this life cycle is
the provisioning and provisioning is the
process of creating user accounts and
assigning access rights and this occurs
after verifying the user's identity and
approving access request.
So these are different steps in the this
life cycle and the first one is the
provisioning and provisioning is
provided after request is access request
is made. After request the identity of
the user is proven and then the accounts
are created to which then access is
granted. Then accounts are used account
use phase and finally account are
deprovision when the user leaves the
organization or changes role.
So deprovisioning is the process of
removing or disabling access when it is
no longer needed. Deprovisioning occurs
when a user leaves the organization when
uh the user changes role or when a
system account is retired or
decommissioned. So system account or the
service accounts. These are nonhuman
accounts.
Action during deprovisioning include
revoking, disabling or deleting accounts
or permissions and retaining records for
audit and accountability.
Our next step is the periodic access
review. So the purpose of periodic
access review is that it ensure to
ensure that all accounts and privileges
are still valid and appropriate. And key
actions include to identify unused or
unnecessary accounts and remove them to
detect excessive privileges and reduce
them and find missing access if there is
any and provision new access if
justified.
So key points include provisioning is
equal to granting access after identifi
identity verification. Deprovisioning is
removing or disabling access when no
longer needed. Regular access review
maintains security and compliance.
And we need to keep some accounts
disabled for audit trails and
accountability.
So account access review is a process to
verify that all user and system accounts
have appropriate access based on their
role or function
and this review ensure that both human
and nonhuman that is system service
internet of thing or API accounts follow
the principle of least privilege.
So we have two types of accounts. User
accounts which are assigned to
individual and they are used for daily
operational access. And then we have
system or service accounts which are
nonuman accounts. Nonhuman accounts used
for backup maintenance or automated
task. They also include internet of
thing devices and API integration.
So what should be the account access
review frequency? So review frequency
may depend on regulatory or compliance
requirements and risk level of the
account account. For example, if the
account is nonadministrator account or a
regular user account, the frequency may
be low such as annual review. And if the
account is of high privilege such as
administrative account the frequency may
be high such as the quarterly review.
So what are some elements of an access
review? So during each review we need to
verify verify that all accounts the user
can access the direct and shared
account. We need to know about all the
accounts. The sensitive data are system
accessible through these accounts. The
action that these accounts can perform
such as read, write and delete action.
The excessive privileges that are not
justified by the job role but but may
but these account may have these excess
privileges. inactive or dharm account
and toxic role combination violating
separation of duties.
So system and service accounts review.
So key practices uh during system and
service account review include to define
review policies for non-human accounts
to check for unnecessary default or
local admin accounts to disable accounts
once troubleshooting or service use ends
and to ensure system access aligns with
secure configuration baselines.
So key takeaways include to regularly
access review the regular access
reviews, prevent privilege creep and
insider threats to apply least privilege
and separation of duties principles. Use
automation for efficiency and
consistency
unreed or misconfigure accounts pose
security risk.
Now coming over to account usage review.
So account usage review is done to
verify how accounts are used.
Accounts may be user system or nonhuman
accounts and to identify inappropriate
or unauthorized use of permissions.
Method of account usage review include
through automated tools such as seam
solution through random audits or
periodic reviews and through integration
with JIT or just in time access system
and the goal is to enforce
accountability and detect abuse or
misuse of privileges.
So examples of usage review include
let's suppose there is a scenario a user
accesses administrative credentials.
So the access excess of administrative
credential will be legitimate if it
matches a support ticket or a work case
and will be suspicious if there is no
valid reason and in this case we need to
investigate it immediately. The key
insight is that we need to correlate
privilege use with business context to
detect privilege escalation attempts.
Oh provisioning and deprovisioning
during account usage review. So
provisioning is creating or enabling
access for a user or system and it is
linked to onboarding role change or
system setup. Deprovisioning is removing
suspending or deleting access. It is
essential to prevent ex employees or
unused accounts from retaining access.
and it requires HR IT and security
coordination.
We have some self-provisioning systems
where user can create their own
accounts.
Example of these include user created
accounts such as in ecommerce system or
software as a service solutions.
Controls include to use arbback that is
the role based access control to define
roles such as customer role and customer
support role in e-commerce for example
and to follow identity proofing and
privacy regulations for data deletion
role definition. So role basically
simplifies access management through
grouped permission. Example of role
include IT role which provides access to
technical system, finance role which
provides access to accounting system.
The benefits of roles include that it
provide easier provisioning. It is
easier in provisioning and
deprovisioning and it enforces least
privilege and separation of duties.
What are role design best practices?
These include to follow least privilege
principle, avoid toxic role combination,
for example, approving and processing
payments and to maintain a role to
system access matrix for clarity.
What is the privilege escalation
escalation? Privilege escalation is
gaining elevated permissions beyond
authorized level.
And types of privilege escalation
include vertical escalation and
horizontal escalation. Vertical
escalation is gaining higher privileges.
For example, when a uh regular user
gains admin privileges.
Horizontal escalation is to access other
user resources or systems.
An impact of privilege escalation is the
compromise of confidentiality, integrity
and availability of data.
So what are some legitimate privilege
escalation use cases? So a valid use
cases include temporary admin access for
maintenance or support.
We need to implement break the glass or
pseudo processes for temporary or
legitimate privilege escalation.
Controls
include log and alert when privilege
credentials are used and restrict
permanent admin login for everyday
tasks.
Privilege escalation controls include
sudo in Linux and Unix where temporary
super user access which gives temporary
super user access with reauthentication.
Break the glass or credential walting is
a controlled access with alerts.
Managed service account are nonhuman
accounts limited to specific functions
and they cannot be used for login.
Our next topic is implement
authentication systems. So the purpose
of authentication systems is to verify a
user's identity based on granting access
and the authentication systems supports
both local and networkbased
authentication.
Example include local authentication is
on a single system for example for
example logging into a single computer
or your own PC or laptop. Network
authentic authentication may be through
LDAP or identity as a service.
So remote or federated authentication
are done through Oath, OIDC and SE. We
will go through each of these one by
one.
So what's the difference between local
and federated authentication? So local
authentication is used on one system or
one application only. For example,
Windows local login. Network
authentication uh uses centralized
credential for multiple system for
example LDEP or active directory. And
federated authentication gives cross
organization trust using tokens. Example
include Oath, OIDC and SAM.
So first system is the oath which is the
open authorization not authentication
but authorization.
The purpose of this system is that it is
an open protocol for secure
authorization again not authentication
and it is used in web mobile and desktop
application.
Key roles in this uh protocol on this
authentication system include resource
owner which grants access to data,
resource server which host protected
resources,
client which request access on behalf of
user and authorization server which
issues access tokens.
Example include a mobile application
request access to your Google contacts
using oath tokens.
Open ID connect OIDC.
So it is built on Oath 2.0 and it adds
authentication on top of authorization
that was available in Oath and it
provides federated identity and SSO like
experience. Flow example include a user
selects an identity provider like
Google, Twitter or Facebook. Identity
provide authenticates user and issues
token to relying party. The token
contains user claims upon which the
access is granted. The risk with this
system is that if the identity provider
like Google is down, access to all
connected service services will fail.
Next is the security assertion markup
language SL and its purpose is federated
authentication and SSO for web
application. It uses XML to share
identity and access information.
Rowles include user agent which is a
browser making the request, service
provider which is the web application
requesting identity information. An
identity provider authenticates user and
sends assertion.
Components include assertions which are
identity and authentication information.
Bindings are communication methods.
Protocols include HTTP and so profiles
are combinations for specific
implementation.
An example log into Office 365 using
corporate credentials through Azure AD.
Next is the Keraros which is early SSO
protocol that uses tickets and symmetric
encryption and it is widely used in
Microsoft active directory environments.
Components of Kerros include principle
which is the user or service key
distribution center or KDC
which consist of authentication server
or AS that verifies identity ticket
granting server TGS that issues service
tickets. Authentication flow is as
follows. So the client authenticates and
receives TGT that is ticket granting
ticket. PGT is then exchanged for
service ticket and the service ticket is
presented to service where where the
access is granted.
Next authentication system is the radius
that is remote authentication dialin
user service. So this is a centralized
AAA solution that is authentication,
authorization and accounting
and it was originally originally for
dialin modem access but now it is used
in 802.1x
network login. Function of radius
includes that it validates remote user
credential. It enforces access policies
and tracks session data for example time
and data usage and it is used by VPN's
wireless networks and network devices.
Next is the tech x plus which is
terminal access controller access
control system plus.
So this was a Cisco designed protocol
providing AAA for network devices access
and it is used by network admins logging
into their router switches and firewalls
and features include that it provides
centralized authentication and
authorization. It encrypts the entire
communication session and hence it is
more secure than radius. Radius only
secures the credentials such as username
and passwords and it tracks admin
accounts for audit and accountability.
The key takeaways are to use federated
systems such as OIDC and SEL for
seamless SSO. Cerberos is ideal for
internal enterprise environments. Radius
and tech plus are secure provide secure
network access and device management and
choose authentication based on use case
security need and
scope.
So that's all for this domain. Please
like the video, subscribe and we'll see
you in the next video.